Éric Ducan est avec nous aujourd'hui
bonsoir Éric merci d'être là euh on
voulait parler dans pas politique
aujourd'hui des coulisses des cuisines
de d'élysée évidemment j'ai pensé à toi
parce que tu as été le cuisinier de
trois présidents Jacques Chirac Nicolas
Sarkozi et François Hollande et tu es
venu effectivement avec des des menus
parce que tu voilà tu as composé des
menus et tu as servi pour des dîners qui
étaient quand même complètement
exceptionnel euh Éric d'abord
raconte-nous un peu comment ça se passe
avant de revenir effectivement
aux festivités réceptions comment ça se
passe le quotidien d'un d'un chef anésé
bah en fait moi je m'occupais de la
partie privée en fait de président
et c'était
sous vous inquiétez pas je suis là ah ou
il voilà bon il va dire bonjour à tout
le monde il fait connaissance avec les
li voilà bah oui il fait connaance et en
fait j'étais sous la coupe de Bernard
von qui était le le grand chef à
l'Élysée Bernard bon c'est 40 ans
d'élysée donc une grosse grosse pointure
pour moi c'est mon mentor donc mais
après les coulisses ça se passe comment
c'est que en fait tous les jours on fait
une proposition de menu deux entrées
deux plats de desserts et après ou c'est
madame qui choisit pour Monsieur ou
alors c'est madame qui choisit pour
Monsieur monsieur sous monsieur en
France c'est madame qui choisit pour
Monsieur le menu sous monsieur
c'était pratiquement tout le temps
Madame c'est vrai ah
bon madame était vraiment une maîtresse
de maison en fait ça des qu'on
[Rires]
parle ça
pas oui donc c'était elle plutôt qui
choisissait des menus c'était elle ouis
qui nous donnait plus ou moins les
consignes et qu'est-ce qu'il aimaitirac
jacquesirac il aimait bien il aimait
bien tout il aimait il aimait l'agneau
il aimait il tout il aimait bien les
fruits de mer ilimit mais en fait Chirac
il été servi au plat ouais ah servi au
plat parce que c'était vraiment un très
très bon mangeur en fait ouais oui ça
c'est sûr quel était le plat préféré de
Nicolas Sarkozi le plat préféré de
Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est difficile j'ai pas c'est
ouais j'ai pas forcément de plat préféré
pour lui c'était quelqu'un autant il
aimait le
raffinement SAR autant il aimait euh des
choses simples aussiou hm hm mais c'est
quelqu'un qui avait pour lui la table
c'est pas qu'il aimait pas manger c'est
que pour lui la table était une perte de
temps ouis ah ou ah oui donc il avait
pas le plaisir de de la nourriture comme
l'avait jacquesiracirac lui il
s'installait
quoi install à tablee Monsieur Hollande
d'ailleurs frolland aussi on est pas
suris on pas sur fait Monsieur L
Monsieur Sarkozy
sous en fait pour gagner du temps il
avait supprimé le fromage en fait ah bon
ah parce que c'est entré ple dessert
fromage en principe vous avez tout sur
un
Dîn vous finissez avec 10 kg plus
surtout en repas officiel en repas
officiel il même supprimé le le fromage
pour gagner duc d'cord et F hand non non
il l'
remis
[Applaudissements]
il ma comment vous avez géré la pression
et les attentes liées à votre poste
parce que le niveau est très très élevé
quand même non mais en fait la la plus
grosse difficulté en fait c'est que vous
avez toujours le même client h en face
de vous donc en fait vous aveit ses
interdits et ce qu'il aime le le tout
c'est de se remettre en question tous
les jours avoir de la créativité et
cetera et et retravailler parfois les
mêmes produits mais diff et oui moi je
me demandais si vous aviez j'imagine que
oui mais comment ça comment ça se passe
est-ce que vous avez des goûteurs comme
ça se passait il y a des siècles est-ce
qu'on goûte les plats est-ce qu'on goûte
le fromage pour être sûr qu'il a pas un
pépin que ça pas été empoisonné qu' a
pas quel chose c'est nous qui préparons
l'airp donc en
fait non ce qui arrive parfois je vois
tuas des référen ce qui arrive parfois
par exemple quand c'est l'Israël vous
avez un rabin qui vient et cetera donc
c'est lui qui va constituer l'assiette
pour sans président euh quand vous avez
américain éventuellement vous avez
peut-être quelqu'un qui vous regarde
mais ça s'arrête là il va juste vérifier
que vous vous goûtez les ah vous êtes
sous surveillance pendant que vous
préparez le repasou c'est très rare
c'est très très rare mais c'est vrai que
c'est une vra question sur la sécurité
alimentaire de ce que vous donnez au
invités il y a juste une chose c'est que
par exemple ça arrivait régulièrement
que des des gens s'arrête à l'Élysée
pour offrir un dessert ou des produits
pour le président avec une petite lettre
ça me fait plaisir de vous ouvrir conert
malheureusement les dessert les desserts
ça arrive pas jusqu'à lui et ils vont
directement à la poubelle en fait
[Musique]
ou c'est ça vient pas du chef moi j'ai
une petite question vous avez parlé RIC
il y a quelques instants d'interdit il y
avait des listes de de choses qu'ils
aimaient de de produits qui étaient
interdits quelles étaient les
intolérances des trois présidents pour
lesquels av c'est une question peut-être
un peu CRA qu'est-ce qui pour le bah oui
le leur provoquer des petits problèmes
gastriques alors franchement les trois
pas forc il y avait pas forcément
d'interdit alimentaire par rapport à
leur santé c'est juste arrivé à un
moment quand monsieur Chirac il avait
fait son AVC bon bah là on avait on
avait des consignes un peu strict après
on avait du mal à le tenir quoi parce
que c'est ça il nous appelait pour avoir
de la characuterie
à bien ERC je crois qu'il ait bien le
jein Tony jackirac non al alors rapide
ouais et l'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé l'AB d'alcool bien
sûr voilà ce qu'il a c'est que Madame
mavait donné des consignes plus d'alcool
charuterie et cetera donc c'était
poissons légumes donc là il commençait à
craquer
quoi donc du coup il a il a dit j'ai
trouvé une j'ai trouvé une solution
comme Bernadette boit du du tonic je
vais me mettre au jein
Tony donc vous mettez un petit peu de je
dans
vous remplissez de tonique et surtout
trompez pas de
[Applaudissements]
ver voilà faire faire la blague donc ça
c'était les les petits arrangements
est-ce que François
Hollande est-ce que Françis je suis
désolé on va attendre on va pe-être
faire sortir hè viens allez ça suffit
c'est quoi la blague là donc viens viens
tu viens avec moi regarde voilà donc
est-ce que et est-ce que François hand
lui aussi avait des petites
particularités des des préférences des
préférences préférences son plat préféré
c'est la côte de bœuf ah côte de BF
d'accord oui côte de buf avec des frites
gL à moelle ou tout simple d'accord tout
simple mais pas tous les jours quand
même non va mieux mais pour son
anniversaire enfin quand j'étais encore
là-bas pour son anniversaire on on lui
faisait côte de bœuf avec des des frites
maison tout simplement est-ce qu'il
arrivait que les présidents descendaient
de leurs appartements privés pour aller
prendre des petites choses en cuisine la
nuit en en los ça paraî bizarre il peut
pas savoir non non non c'est pas ça
c'est que de temps en temps on les
croisit neig j'ai une petite
faim mais après c'était souvent ça
m'arrivait de croiser Carla Bruni ou ben
j'ai une petite fin où est-ce que le
saucisson et cetera puis elle vous
laisse le couper elle-même en fait mais
ça reste faut faut partir du principe en
fait moi j'avais pas un homme politique
en face de moi j'avais une
personne que je respectais bien sûr par
rapport au rang
mais derrière ce sont des gens simples
aussi bah oui bien sûr que vous avez
créé un lien je voudrais que vous nous
montriez Éric ce que vous nous avez
apportter peut-être parce que vous avez
aussi et bien dressé des des menus pour
des des dîners un peu on va dire
exceptionnel dans dans le sens où
effectivement peut-être la terre entière
avait les yeux rivés sur sur la France
notamment je pass un dîner où Nicolas
Sarkozi recevait
Kaddafi président libien leader libien
il y avait effectivement beaucoup de
tension beaucoup de beaucoup d'attente
autour de ce dîner alors comment on
compose ce dîner je crois que vous nous
avez apporté le menu Eric alors oui je
alors je suis désolé en le prenant je
l'ai fait tomber ah ça c'est pas c'est
pas de chance ah Z ah oui ah c'est pas
grave ah voilà le menu il y avait quoi
au menu vous l'avez avec avec vous avec
toi euh le menu voilà ouais c'est pas
mal alors alors il y avait il y avait
quoi alors vous vous aviez un moelleux
volail forestier avec des tomates
confites et ensuite vous aviez du gigot
de 7h donc en fait un menu en fait quand
c'est dîner officiel je parle en
officiel c'est Bernard von qui préparait
des est menu et donc c'était envoyé ou
au Président ou à Madame selon comment
ça se passait au niveau ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le le service protocole
donnait à Bernard des des informations
sur les interdits les allergènes des
présidents étrangers d'accord et suite à
ça on on se basse par rapport plus ou
moins à leur culture pour effectuer des
des menus en fait et justement par
rapport à ces menus on a on a vu quand
Emmanuel Macron a reçu Charles I il y a
toute une polémique notamment au niveau
des vins qui lui ont servi du coup du
repas et cetera est-ce que c'est des
idées reçues est-ce que parfois ces
repas sont finalement plutôt simples et
pourrait être presque préparé par
monsieur et madame tout le monde ou
est-ce que c'est toujours des menus qui
sont très chers avec des des matières
premières très chères des vins très cher
ou est-ce que non c'est access là-dessus
moi je vais je vais avoir une politique
qui fait
que quand il y a des gens qui Râ en
disant ouais mais ça coûtait cher c'est
ceci c'est cela personnellement c'est
des choses que je comprends pas pourquoi
je m'explique juste dessus c'est que en
fait l'Élysée c'est la vitrine de la
France l'Élysée on reçoit tous les pays
du monde entier et on se doit de
défendre les producteurs français tous
ceux qui sont producteurs français
travaillent d' rchepied pour sortir des
produits d'exception et on a cette
richesse en France donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait c'est que sur des dîners d'État que
ça soit de l'entrée au vin comme vous
vous le dites ou des digestifs il faut
défendre tout ça et il faut les mettre
en avant donc on se doit de faire de
l'excellence et c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que la gastronomie française
a été reconnue sous l'UNESCO quand même
faut quand même le savoir et on a une
une telle belle réputation dans le monde
entier que on se doit de préserver ses
richesse donc après quand j'entends des
polémiques ouais ça a touch ça a coûté
temp ça a coûtaé tempant mais il faut le
regarder autrement en fait parce que là
c'est vraiment la les valeurs de la
France ouais ça c'est le point de vue
effectivement du chef qui a servi trois
président et voilà point de vue mais
aussi je parle pas que de moi c'est que
je parle aussi des petits parce que on
fait travailler des petits producteurs
oui des petits producteurs qui
travaillent 7 choisissez d'ailleurs les
les producteurs parce que tout le monde
doit se battre les producteurs de
légumes de viande tout le monde fournir
des lysées on avait un boulanger qui
fournissait la la galette pour pour le
président de publ est tout l'lisé
comment vous les choisissez les
producteurs il y a une course bah après
c'est pas qu'il y a une course c'est que
après c'est du bouche à oreille et
cetera on se renseigne aussi comment il
produit comment il élève ses produits ou
qui qui fait pousser ses produits mais
on regarde on fait attention à comment
il fait parce que derrière si on prend
ce
producteur derrière indirectement faut
qu'il soit proche il y a pas un un
turnover je sais pas de producteur allez
une année année to voilà ça c'est par
exemple Jacques Chirac euh la fois où il
y avait eu la gripe avière sur les
volailles bah il y avait un dîner h il a
fait changer le le menu il a dit vous me
mettez de la volaille ce soir au menu je
ve montrer à tout le monde Queen fait
notre volaille elle est improchable quoi
en fait d'accord je trouve ça beau quoi
ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est beau c'est
aussi ce sont aussi des des messages
politiques donc voilà pour les les
coulisses de c'est passionnant he ces
histoires ces annecdotes vous avz un
restaurant aujourd'hui dans le 15e
arrondissement
les tris présidents ou oui je
con oui oui je les connaissais oui oui
enfin une habitu oui effectivement
l'occasion d'y aller c'est pas très lo
de mon ancien lieu de travail pour tout
vous dire donc on se connaitt bien éc et
moi Éric effectivement raconte des
histoires passionnantes